you want to say anything to the
audience go ahead FaceTime what do you
want me to say he looks like Will Smith
a little bit I love
you name say that say k name out of
your name go ahead out of your freaking
mouth oh you're good at that that's good
you can why any cuss though I'm used to
have no okay that sounds weird oh
this there this amazing hey thank you
crying iy L do you want to come take one
gravity here he is a lot of gravity
there you go want to sit right there
yeah yeah he'll get you you know those
is the
front yeah the are n i people who are
listening to this on star high or
they're they're not anymore no a lot of
Dr uh thing you got John
[Laughter]
and yeah he it's dark right and then if
he would have told me yeah that racist
like yeah I don't know it looks
racist like it it looks like it looks
racist is he doing it
right oh look at like it's you're not
doing it right getting who Tails you're
not doing it right I need a napkin or a
tail get a nkin or a tail a in I need
AEG what are you gonna say a EG not it
so the game is trying to guess what m is
saying go ahead you say something you gu
guy is saying I need need a spit rag I
need a spit rag
need getting close he's drilling I'm
Drilling and a need oh God I need a
drill egg oh this is disgusting this is
absolutely dis why is no one hering
tails is thank you thank
you my God this is so
disgusting look we had
John
nikf
Alex not Jackie okay so I'm going to
read a hung no should I read a h no want
to read a hung oh come on har what got
the Jew come I don't know listen excited
honestly I think I lost
fin drilling
Drilling I lost man oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
God who do I have to [__] to get off
this
show I think just being on the show you
are
[__]
he